of course is anger tomorrow so when
anyone even looks at the wrong way in
their own words her chilling and
depressing insight into life behind bars
over the course of a week we spoke to
three different inmates at prisons
across the country snatched
conversations on they're illegally
smuggled in mobile phones were
protecting their identities all said
violence was rife Jake serving time in a
London prison said day to day conditions
were unbearable he says the situation is
all the more intolerable when inmates
time out of their cells is limited
inmates know there's likely to be little
public sympathy for them but Steve
serving time in the East of England said
much of the increase in prison violence
is linked to their growing frustration
are you finding that you're locked in
your cells much longer than you ever
where in the past
last week's Wako to jails across England
and Wales present officers are this week
in argent talks with government looking
for solutions to unprecedented levels of
violence done behind bars in the North
West said drugs are certainly fueling
some of the violence but so he says is
the fact many inmates of mental health
issues
or fair enough people need to go to work
and feel safe but they're working in
prison full of people with mental health
problems there's no therapy you know
I've been asking for the North counselor
failed right but things benefitting
people they get rid of to get anything
we need to be violent aggressive like
all three inmates we spoke to were
extremely pessimistic about the prospect
of improvements anytime soon inmates and
prison officers don't see eye to eye on
much but on the likelihood of FUD
they're very serious violence they're in
full agreement mark white Sky News
[Music]